Yeah.
An event of major international
significance so occurred this week.
Australia announced plans to protect
almost half its oceanic territory up
from an already stellar 20% the
announcement was made it real plus 20
the world summit evaluating progress
made on environmental and economic
issues since 1992 why is this so
important?
It's simple.
We're catching all the fish down the
chain from large to small with high tech
rapidity.
It's a war on fish and we're winning.
Marine protected areas give nature a
fighting chance.
When Europeans first came to the new
world,
they encountered see life and quantities
that stagger modern imagination lobsters
so common that only the poor would eat
them.
Reach 20 pounds.
Massive oyster beds yielded dinner plate
sized specimens in a single day.
A fisherman could hook 600 giant
sturgeon,
which could weigh a ton on cream beach
north of Boston.
The shellfish would pile up three feet
thick after a nor'easter.
I've been there recently after a storm
on four miles of beach,
I found a lobster trap,
a horseshoe crab dad and one starfish.
I found that painful.
None of this exists anymore and more
besides is gone.
It's an environmental catastrophe,
but it's also an economic and aesthetic
catastrophe and it's caused by
ignorance.
Particularly in Canada.
We had one of the world's great
resources in the cod fishery for years.
We blamed it's decline on foreigners.
In 1982 we won the right to extend our
coastal limit from seven to 200 miles.
By 1992 we had managed the cod to
virtual extinction and the Atlantic
fishery was closed.
40,000
people lost their jobs.
We learned nothing from this.
Canada is willfully blind and it's ocean
management strategy and we keep lying to
the world about our intentions to do
better.
In 1992 we pledged to protect one fifth
of our oceanic territory.
By 2012 we promised the same thing again
in 2002 and 2003 and 2005 where are we
after all these promises?
We've reserved less than 1% and phishing
is still allowed in almost all of that.
Even the radically business like
Americans have done better with 5% of
their oceans protected.
Does our word on the international stage
means so little,
and if so,
why?
Some of it is the consequence of the
ideological divide between
environmentalist's and those on the
right.
Harper's conservatives regard anyone
concerned with ecological issues as an
enemy.
The in gratitude environmentalist's
typically show for the benefits of the
modern economy assures such a response
we must get beyond such
counterproductive enmity and quickly.
Proper management of the oceans would be
good for everyone.
Fishermen,
tourist,
consumer,
businessmen and politicians alike.
If we continue along our present path in
a few years,
there will be nothing but jellyfish left
and we've started to eat those.
We should muster up the foresight of the
Australians adopt the processes they
have developed so successfully and
manage what we are responsible for
gratefully and intelligently for the
agenda with Steve Pakan,
I'm Jordan Peterson,
support Ontario's public television.
donate@tvo.org.